stereo photography has been around since
1840 and it involves replicating the
process by which we actually see which
is from two slightly different positions
so you can set up a camera to take or to
keep regular cameras in this case to
take pictures simultaneously essentially
you want to have each camera set the
exact same way and you want to have them
shoot the pictures simultaneously which
is easy to do with these cameras because
they have electronic triggering so you
get very good synchronous firing and
they also have click stops on the zooms
so you can set it three different zoom
positions and it clicks in so that
you're at each lens will be at the same
soom stop and this camera also has an
additional feature that allows you to
change the width of your eye spacing of
the pictures that you're taking so for a
more distant scene like a city scape you
wouldn't see the three dimensionality
unless you are spread out and then from
indoor stuff or anything relatively
close you want them to be roughly the
same separation as your eyes so this
viewer is for viewing one stereo pair at
a time manually loaded so there are two
slides taken by your double camera setup
that are glued down onto a piece of
acrylic and they need to be properly
aligned so that the heights are the same
you can then view them so that your left
eye sees what the left camera took and
your right eye sees what the right
camera took and it should reproduce
exactly the way you would see the scene
and then this viewer is similar to that
one except that it has ten different
views in it these are loops they're used
by graphic artists or people examining
slides the viewer is made out of acrylic
and aluminum machined and this one has
the additional feature that the eye
separation can be varied for people who
different eye separation so you can see
it comfortably and it's an
interchangeable magazine compared to
other 3d methods when you're looking
directly at a slide you get a very good
resolution and contrast so it's pretty
much the best 3d experience you can have